[Música]
no
mañana
bueno
yo hoy os quería hablar de arte en
concreto de cómo internet y la lo fácil
que es ahora compartir difundir y crear
contenidos en internet está poniendo a
prueba la función de los artistas y el
propio concepto de arte en concreto lo
que voy a hacer es comparar cuatro
movimientos artísticos del siglo 20 con
la actualidad vamos a empezar una
pequeña comparación histórica tenemos
aquí dos imágenes una de ellas es la de
un sacerdote un pastor americano en
detroit consciente una misa para que la
industria automovilística vuelva a
florecer no es el contexto de la crisis
de 2008
una crisis que aún estamos viviendo y
viene aparejada con una crisis
democrática las elecciones repetición de
lecciones todo el rato temas como el
break shit
y esto lo podemos comparar muy
fácilmente con un espectro como el de
hace 90 años con la otra foto de que
tenemos también
en el contexto de la crisis del 29
estábamos en una gran crisis económica y
también en una crisis democrática
similar entre dos guerras mundiales uno
de los factores que también están aquí
presentes son la introducción de dos
nuevas formas de comunicación
en concreto el cine y la fotografía que
alteran también y esto es lo que nos
interesa para esta charla 'la teherán
como los artistas están produciendo su
obra en concreto los primeros en
aprender o en utilizar estas nuevas
técnicas son los dadaístas tenemos en la
imagen un fotomontaje crítico con hitler
veis que le pone unas monedas está
explorando
el artista edición hetfield está
explorando estas nuevas técnicas de
montaje también es muy son muy
reconocibles los collage de analistas en
los que ya no hace falta ir a la
academia de arte a aprender durante años
a pintar como velázquez sino que
cogiendo unas revistas papel pegamento y
tijeras podemos crear nuestra propia
composición y esto volvió a ser arte
pero en realidad es una degradación del
propio concepto de arte porque como digo
no hace falta saber pintar
exquisitamente los surrealistas llevan
esta idea a toda la concepción de la
sociedad y lo que hacen es degradar todo
el espectro político
en concreto ellos dicen que el
surrealismo está indefinible mente
asociado a la palabra revolución y que
son expertos en la revuelta y quieren
sistematizar la confusión del mundo de
la realidad en la imagen tenemos a un
surrealista que está supuestamente
insultando a un cura vemos que está
intentando degradar este constructo
moral católico imperante en esa época la
foto es de 1926 si avanzamos en el
tiempo tenemos el caso de los
situacionistas que cogen este espíritu
revolucionario del surrealismo
y lo llevan a los años 60 es una época
en la que ya tenemos el cine que están
homogeneizando toda la sociedad
occidental
también tenemos la televisión que está
siendo introducida en esa época en todos
los hogares en eeuu en europa vemos aquí
una especie de proto meme que dice esta
noche espectáculo en casa y de borde
líder de los situacionistas habla de la
sociedad del espectáculo como es
unidireccional
y como parte de los poderes hacia el
pueblo sin que éste pueda responder él
quiere romper este constructo mediático
y quiere que la gente pueda expresarse
esta idea de romper este constructo
mediático lo llevan a cabo sobre todo un
movimiento nacional 70 que dura hasta
hoy que es el cultura jamming una de las
formas más básicas es como vemos alterar
la publicidad cambiando el mensaje para
que la gente la población pueda tener un
espíritu crítico otra de las cosas que
hacían en concreto uno de los cultos
jammers más famosos que hoy escacs era
crear noticias falsas él se ha dedicado
toda su vida desde que comenzó en el 76
a crear muros mediáticos que los medios
tragaban como verdaderos y daban a la
ciudadanía como verdaderos con haciendo
un constructo de la realidad que
realmente es falso porque eso no sucedió
lo interesante del movimiento cultural
ya no eres que como digo dura hasta
ahora y en el año 93 un crítico cultural
mark déry teoriza sobre él en ese año en
eeuu y hay un internet incipiente
entonces martelly se pregunta en su
manifiesto jammer si internet va a poder
primero romper el oligopolio mediático
dando voz a los periodistas cyberpunk
como el de llama a que puedan publicar
sus propias noticias sin estar mediados
por una empresa como sería un periódico
y también se pregunta si en el futuro
habrán nódulos también los llama el así
en los que cada persona puede expresarse
esto es una comparación obvia con las
redes sociales
ahora vamos a pasar a la siguiente fase
vamos a comparar todo esto que hemos
visto con la actualidad
en primer lugar noticias falsas no hace
falta incidir en que estamos en un mundo
totalmente sobre informado y mucha
desinformación es falsa las noticias
falsas rompen este constructo mediático
que quería romper marter y los
situacionistas pero lo hacen de una
forma perniciosa porque realmente lo que
crean es generan un clima de crispación
política hay tanta información que cada
persona puede elegir la que mejor se
adecua a su modo de ver el mundo
entonces se reafirman esas ideas lo que
pasa es que se va alejando de la
realidad y creyendo que el bando
contrario son son malas personas o
directamente no son personas todos
habéis conocido los ejemplos de odio de
mensajes de odio etcétera que se dan en
internet no también vemos cómo esos
nódulos de los que hablaba mark déry que
son las redes sociales las vemos en
acción en este caso tenemos una crítica
que
y unos usuarios
a mcdonald's en este caso por
promocionar una fiesta que es
que es americana los situacionistas se
lamentaban en los años 50 de que la
escritura automática que habrían que
habían inventado los surrealistas se
había convertido en brainstorming para
las empresas y que esto suponía una
vacuna contra el virus revolucionario
porque los trabajadores ahora se sentían
escuchados y por lo tanto no iban a
protestar en este caso podemos decir
algo así como la gente puede criticar a
mcdonald's en este caso en internet pues
ya esa sensación de queja ya está
resuelta por lo tanto no hace falta ir a
mcdonald's a protestar realmente no lo
interesante de estas comunicaciones es
que realmente no son revolucionarias
aquí tenemos unos ejemplos de cómo unas
personas hablan al campo este espíritu
revolucionario que habían pensado los
los situacionistas los culturales
realmente queda anulado totalmente
además también
y poder relacionarte de forma muy
cercana con las empresas de tú a tú no
hace falta que escriba una carta
empezando por muy señores míos da igual
que hablen con festivas con faltas de
ortografía porque las empresas siempre
te van a responder bien siempre van a
tener una carita sonriente con la que
responderte está ese trato cercano que
también supone una vacuna este virus
revolucionario no seguimos para atrás en
nuestro repaso tenemos aquí un vídeo de
una señora que retransmite en directo su
sesión de fitness matutino hemos visto
el caso de la sociedad el espectáculo de
los situacionistas en las que ellos
querían romper está unidireccionalidad
está rota con estos ejemplos porque
ahora todo el mundo puede retransmitir
lo que quiera el problema es que no
retransmite en contenido revolucionario
ni
de liberación sino que retransmite en su
propio día a día reproducen el contenido
que los medios de comunicación lanzaban
antes antes teníamos en forma con jane
fonda ahora tenemos en forma con x
podemos hablar no de una sociedad del
espectáculo sino de una sociedad del
micro espectáculo de forma paralela
las surrealistas como he comentado antes
hablaban de la de sistematizar la
confusión del mundo de la realidad este
meme que tenemos aquí es original todos
los que vamos a ver aquí los que voy a
poner a partir de ahora son memes
encontrados sobre todo en facebook y
realmente lo que estaba rompiendo el
oligopolio mediático porque desde el
franquismo no se ha dado voz desde los
medios de comunicación principales todos
estos 40 años de democracia al
movimiento más franquista que ha estado
ahí no pero internet sí que les ha
brindado una oportunidad de salir a la
luz y querer expresarse ellos también
exigen libertad de expresión
el problema obviamente es que de nuevo
no es un mensaje revolucionario sino que
es un mensaje contrarrevolucionario del
nuevo probamos la ingenuidad de estos
movimientos revolucionarios del siglo 20
collage habíamos visto la figura del
collage de la lista aquí tenemos un
collage con el logo del pp al
expresidente del gobierno mariano rajoy
sí cuando vimos esta imagen de hitler
con monedas tenía un espíritu
abiertamente crítico en este caso no en
este caso tiene un espíritu totalmente
anulatorio vemos que está rodeado de
imágenes positivas naturaleza de una
virgen la bandera de españa entonces
realmente tampoco hay un espíritu
revolucionario sino que hay un espíritu
de enraizarse en el progreso
hay menos para todos los gustos a estas
nuevas formas de arte les tenemos que
llamar post arte exige un nuevo nombre
porque de nuevo ya no es una elite
artística la que lanza un mensaje sino
que todo el mundo puede hacerlo por lo
tanto tenemos que darle un nombre y es
post arte una de las características más
interesantes del post arte es que no es
la estética la que define la calidad de
la obra de arte sino que es la ideología
yo voy a estar de acuerdo con este mes y
soy de ponemos pero me va a disgustar un
montón si soy del pp lo mismo ocurre con
el meme que hemos visto anteriormente
hemos hablado de degradación también
cuando hemos visto esta imagen de hitler
o la propia pantalla de televisión con
un mensaje estamos degradando el símbolo
es representado este es un meme hecho
para las elecciones de 2016 del 26 de
julio en el que vemos un logo que es el
de paypal obviamente esto debería ser el
logo del pp pero la persona que lo ha
hecho
se ha confundido no ha puesto el logo
del pp tiene este un espíritu crítico no
directamente es una equivocación por lo
tanto esto también pone en cuestión está
este énfasis de los culture jammers
el alterar la comunicación como vemos
esto con el anuncio de marlboro
realmente tenemos la capacidad de
analizar eso realmente nos hacemos
preguntas pues yo creo que a la vista de
esto es difícil de averiguar
y walter benjamin en 1935 estableció
tres formas de funciones rituales en el
arte la primera era subimos un cuadro de
una virgen en una iglesia la primera
función ritual es la religiosa vamos a
la iglesia a rezar esa virgen en este
caso este mes propongo la primera
función ritual el post arte también
tiene funciones rituales exactamente
igual
sería la persona que va a la web donde
está colgado y la ve la segunda función
ritual que dice y walter benjamin llega
con la ilustración cuando la burguesía
ve un énfasis artístico en las obras
entonces cogen obras de la iglesia la
llevan al museo para poderlas contemplar
de una manera distinta ya no hay un
espíritu religioso sino que es un
espíritu artístico en este caso esta
obra de post arte al yo a verla
comisariado para todas vosotras se trata
aquí estamos realizando esa función
museística producirlo de alguna manera
la tercera función el ritual de la obra
de arte viene con la reproducción
técnica una vez que ya se ha inventado
la fotografía podemos hacer una foto de
esa ese cuadro esa virgen y nos podemos
poner en nuestra casa siendo poseedores
de la obra de arte en los memes
obviamente cada vez que tú lo miras en
un dispositivo tienes una copia de esa
obra de arte en tu teléfono en tu
computador
lo interesante el post arte es que
establece una cuarta función ritual y es
que dado que todo el mundo puede tiene
acceso a las mismas herramientas puede
relacionarse haciendo obras de post arte
antes podríamos hacer una película pero
el espectador no estaba al mismo nivel
como para hacer una película pues ya
pelar que es pintar un cuadro pero yo no
sé pintar un cuadro como el de velázquez
pero ahora en cambio si puedo tener un
meme como éste que vemos y una usuaria
le pone su cara encima reivindicando lo
de alguna manera y además si esto luego
lo acuerda en facebook va a tener
comentarios de algo que buenos días qué
guapa no sé qué enhorabuena tal
dentro de todo esto que hemos visto
dónde queda la función del artista
realmente mi propuesta es que el arte
hoy en día o el artista que quiere hacer
algo no tiene mucho mucho sentido dado
que hay una ingente cantidad de gente
haciendo cosas de producción
entonces donde queda hacer una
producción artística pretenciosamente
artística pues yo creo que es
irrelevante el artista hoy en día lo que
tendría que hacer es comisariar toda
esta avalancha de obras de post arte
para seleccionar las más relevantes y
que realmente esas puedan tener un peso
histórico me gustaría acabar con una
reflexión sobre las guerras mundiales
que hemos visto al principio
marshall mcluhan dijo en 1970 que nos
habíamos enfrentado a una tercera guerra
mundial sin distinción entre población
civil de civil y militar y que iba a ser
una guerra de guerrillas de la
comunicación aquí vemos como en los
ejemplos que hemos visto antes a un
franco con un corazoncito que está
intentando poner la figura de franco más
amable en el internet no entonces
estamos en esta guerra de comunicación
ya estamos en el ya hemos visto cómo ha
empezado lo que no sabemos es cómo va a
acabar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]